hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so finally here we are we
had this massive move up with strong
volumes on both amc and gamestop so
let's analyze today what happened during
yesterday's price action let's try to
see if this strong move up was created
by shorts by my depositions or if it was
coming from natural bias so to do that
we are going to analyze the synthetic
short interest the regular short
interest uh we're gonna try to find some
information about those market dynamics
i'm also gonna try to give you here some
cool option strategies that you could
use to play the squeeze and we are going
to discuss what are the targets so let's
get into it
[Music]
okay first amc guys so let me take a
step back and analyze with you guys uh
quickly what happened during the past
year all right so first move up then
correction during three months then
second move up this move up guys i know
that a lot of you saw those videos but a
lot of you as well just arrived after
that so basically here we followed
exactly elliott wave and fibonacci
theory so the levels were 35
70 you know 65 75 and then pulled back
to uh 35 so this is exactly what
happened after that here we had uh you
know this correction lasts a bit longer
than expected and we had here especially
a fake out all right so we had one fake
out in this move down but the second one
was the good one and once again the
techniques that you can use to know if
the breakout is very good or not so here
we have one breakout but you can see
that the macd here during this breakout
that was here so i just connect the
highs that are here sorry i guess you
don't see it very well up
okay it's very interesting because you
know here i connect the eyes okay and i
have here breakout but here you can see
that the macd was not going higher on
the flowers okay the magdie was going
here lower all right on the hourly we
had the divergence but that's why it's
good to have those divergences on two
time frames here the situation is
different you can see that the move down
is a weaker and you can see it using
macd divergences on both four hours and
hourly so when you have a double
divergence plus a breakout it's looking
very good so this is the reason why i'm
so bullish for the past two weeks a week
you know since we have this breakout
here i was neutral
and here we had this perfect breakout
like i said guys on my discord it's a
textbook situation break out retest and
bam we move higher so what happened here
what do you think happened there was no
news guys all right we are gonna analyze
the short market very soon but i can
already tell you that this move up is
coming from big institutional clients
maybe even hedge funds that are playing
the move up all right those guys entered
massively in the amc trade and the
reason behind is probably this breakout
they saw this breakout and they were
like all right something is coming let's
get into it so this is what happened
here and i'm gonna show you how i guess
this using the short interest but first
what are
the different resistances that we're
having here so to know that any of them
so i put them here could give you a
selling reaction now the situation is
you know so of course it's very bullish
of course it's looking like it's going
to go higher but it's it might be messy
as well so here are the different
resistance that we're having you just
take the highs of the move down all
right and you try to have some reactions
in the past so i did that already it
gives me 46.5 50 55 61 and 65. those are
the levels where we might see a
potential rejection but definitely this
looks like the beginning of something we
have the momentum with us it would very
likely keep going higher in terms of
targets guys nothing has changed and
it's been like this for like two
almost three months all right so the
targets are the same we are chasing this
fifth wave
and we using fib extensions then we
measure so you can do it in two
different ways either you consider that
this is the fifth coming from this one
plus three it's giving you one or one
point six one eight so 98 or 140 but
i rather see a fifth wave from this move
okay
and which gives me 91 and 130 i'm just
using one two one and one to 1.618 fib
projections for the fifth wave coming
from wave one plus three all right so
this is the fibonacci and elliott wave
theory combined and it worked very well
before so i'm gonna keep using it and
updating you guys with those levels
so yeah this is it um everything can
happen here of course we never know but
most likely we will keep going higher
this is looking good to me but it's
tough to end to here for those who were
not able to enter lower uh and we had
many opportunities guys i gave you most
of this levels so 35 was one of them 33
was one of them
we had here during this breakout and
pullback a lot of opportunities to enter
but still if you are not there i think
that the most like the best thing to do
is to go to the option market and i'm
going to show you what we can do but
first let's analyze the short interest
all right so uh now let's have a look
guys at uh the synthetic short interest
we're also going to have a look at the
regulation trust and the day to cover so
we start with nmc so basically what i'm
doing here for those who are seeing the
spreadsheet for the first time
bam i'm here retrieving all the open
interest for all the option market i
then check by strike and by maturities
what is the position i use the
volatility of every option that is here
and then
compute the delta myself we're using
blackshots formula
basic stuff and by doing that i have all
the synthetic short interest for any
stock which is very helpful so for amc
we can see that the synthetic shot is
nine percent so basically we have two
billion usd of short position coming so
this is the real exposure after the
delta weight
and that is coming mostly as you guys
can see from so the 40 strike and 145
strike which creates a lot of gamma on
the upside and this is the reason why we
can go from nine percent to 16.5
which is quite high the highest i've
seen for the max synthetic short is
around 20 22
it was before the last squeeze so
we are here having a very strong bullish
momentum that would happen on the upside
if we start to go there this is for
example what happened yesterday we
crossed the 40 strike so this is the
reason why we had this very strong move
up so this was probably coming not from
regular shorts that have 16 percent but
rather from the market makers that uh
have seen the 40 strike call the price
action was going through this for this
cycle so they had no other option than
buying back some shells so they created
this but now let's have a look so the
total shot is the regular shot as of
30th of july 16.7
once again we've seen this equal to 20
uh you know before on amc short interest
so we had between so you see in may june
we had around 20 so it was a bit more
but it's still substantial 17
to that we add the nine percent that we
get from the synthetic shot that is a
lot guys nine percent is huge especially
when it's coming from those high strikes
then we have 25 percent of total short
interest and we can compute the ddc day
to cover which is equal to the number of
short shares total number divided by the
for example here i took the monthly
so one month the monthly average volume
trading so basically it says that shorts
would need 1.4 days to cover their
positions if they want to so it's not a
lot guys all right for squeeze we
usually have around three
five even maybe 10 dtc
and that is actually putting a lot of
pressure on shots so here shorts have
time all right so those who are buying
you have a little bit of market makers
but they didn't start the move all right
they didn't start the move because those
guys they need to buy only if it goes
higher they carry a negative gamma
position
but
here the move was probably started by a
big institutional clients and maybe
hedge funds that just played this
breakout guys all right they just played
this move up here and they saw that
something was happening and they entered
massively and by doing that you can see
when we check when this volume has
started so all right the biggest volume
is here so it's going to 15 minutes
which levels so you see the volume has
started here okay this volume was
already very unusual okay so this is the
beginning right here is the first time
we have such a high volume you can see
guys
bam higher than everything else in the
past on the 15 minutes time frame only
the bearish days were sometimes bigger
and this move happened at 7 45 so it was
at 39 all right so they decided here to
suddenly
buy massively and then we had those
other
massive buying orders that were probably
coming from market makers so this is a
double phenomenon and it is likely to
continue i mean the bullish momentum was
strong yesterday
and it might get even stronger because
more people are talking about it more
retail is going to start to buy it looks
like you know they still have some
ammunition that they can fire on the
shorts hedge funds are gonna start to
cut the position market makers are gonna
be forced to buy back so there are a lot
of reason we still have this breakout
with us and we are looking that we are
in the fifth wave so everything looks
very good to me but once again there is
no guarantee of anything and this is the
reason why i think that options are very
very nice instruments to play this move
up so let me show you what i have shown
you before and what cool we can do okay
or maybe first i'm gonna show you let's
check quickly gme chart first so then
i'm gonna show you the synthetic shot
for gme
so not a lot for me to say on gm chart
we can see that same thing the volume
started to kick in quite early so
probably the same investors that were
buying both gme and amc they were you
know diversifying kind of i don't have
here very precise levels we blew the 185
resistance level with very strong
volumes so this is looking good next
resistance is 235 240 and 290 roughly no
sorry it's lower no it's this
so
here i think that it's easier for me to
analyze amc and i'm just applying the
same analysis to gme so i think that anc
is you know we had a very clear breakout
with uh bearish divergence we have a
bullish divergence we have it here as
well by the way you can see market
making lower lows and the magazine
making higher lows so we have this
bullish divergence as well on gamestop
so it's looking good as well so you know
i think those two will keep moving
together and i have a target of 800
still the same for a very long time and
it's not moving okay very quickly the
synthetic shot for gme so here 1.4 25
okay this is the interesting information
now jimmy bam
let's have a look at that i really like
this spreadsheet now that i built i can
check the synthetic shot for every stock
and by the way guys for those who are
with me on discord i want to make a
little game you're going to give me all
the names that you think are heavily
shorted and we're gonna screen it and
see what is the synthetic shot and try
to spot which market caps are actually
you know small enough for a squeeze to
happen so i want to make this with you
very very soon so here jimmy what can we
see
okay many information first
up yet synthetic short alright so i'm
getting it
bam bam bam everything is computing by
itself i just need to wait
and see the results okay here we go so
synthetic shot six percent so smaller
than amc but the max
synthetic short look at the
at the 690 and this is what the 950
strike is very very is massive all right
the position here is absolutely massive
so this is looking very good as well and
this is the reason why we're having even
more gamma guys here we can go from 6 to
16 okay
so this is looking quite good but for
now the total shot is smaller we have
six percent plus 10 percent of regular
short but the date the volume is much
lower so day to cover is 4.3 guys okay
so gamestop is kind of three times
more likely to squeeze just in terms of
volume than amc so everything here needs
to be worked together we have some
information from the total shot from the
gamma and from the dtc so the the total
shot is higher on amc but as the volume
is lower it can create more damage to
the shorts on gme so i think that you
know both are very interesting to play
now let's go back to what we can do what
kind of
cool option strategy we can make so i
would go to the 17th of september
because
it's happening now guys so a shorter
maturity is actually easier to handle
this situation so here first let me show
you what kind of option strategy i
showed you last time so last time i was
telling you you go for this one so you
sell the 24 put
okay
amc was trading at 32
all right
and for 50 us dollars it was 60. i told
you that you can go for this strategy
you can sell the 24 buy the 40 okay so
here plus one so let me show you again
how this works you sell this one because
you are not scared to finish below the
support
you buy this one and you make it cheaper
by selling the very upside call all
right so it costs you 50 us dollar and
you can make up to six thousand now we
are here right so this strategy went
from zero roughly to 670. so you made
some money okay you follow basically the
green curve here which is the present
value and the orange curve is the
difference between the payoff at
maturity and the present value so
basically whenever it's positive it
means that the time is playing with you
that the more you wait the more money
you're gonna have
at maturity so basically it's those
strategies that have a positive time
value are good to keep as long as
possible
because the time is going with you and
so this was the strategy we had and so
now for those who are in this strategy
what you can do first
okay you don't care about this one it's
very limited risk because the 24 put is
very far away now
so
buying back is an option because you
want to eliminate this risk for chip
so
this is a good risk management but
keeping it is a very limited risk and
it's still reducing 100 usd your
total premium so up to you i would
personally stop it so that i eliminated
fully the risk so here we put a zero we
cut this then the hundred strike here
call has a volatility of 250 percent all
right so it's a lot but the 130 has even
more and look at the difference this one
cost 340 us dollar and this one 300 so
basically for 38 dollars you can go to a
130 so i would buy back the 100 and sell
the 103 so your payoff is now something
like this okay so you cannot lose money
below 40. so this costs you uh 100 us
dollars or 200 130 us dollars to do but
i think it's a good strategy and now
your max performance is 9 000 up to 120
so we have more room and this is going
to be easier to unwind if we go close to
the 100 level so i would personally do
that if i was in that trade if i was not
what i would do right now 30 is our next
support and very strong support
especially after a breakup like this we
it will act very well as support so we
are not scared everything below 30. so
we sell this one and we are now trading
at 44 so we gonna buy the next support
above us which is 50. so you buy the 50
you sell the 130
and you sell the 30. so you have a
strategy that costs 250 us dollars and
that can make up to 8 000 us dollars so
this is a very very nice strategy to
make that is very limited in terms of
risk because you're not losing money
above 30 uh you only lose your premium
so it's perfect to play the squeeze
because if amc actually drops and closes
i don't know in september around 35 you
would not lose money if you really don't
want to have any risk you can also not
sell any put which is easier and you
just go for cold spread all right
instead of buying naked calls all right
guys just for you to see the realized
volatility is 195 which means that the
average move daily you just divided by
16 is 12 so amc is moving roughly
12 per day for the past two months and
you can see that the volatility here of
the 50 strike call is 187 so it's very
fair the implied volt is equal to the
realized volt so it's fair so you want
to buy this but the 120 strike look the
implied volt is 280
so you don't want to buy this this is a
scam done by market makers to protect
themselves so you want to be selling it
that's why in my strategies i will
always show you what are the nice
volatility to buy and to sell and if
it's fair or not buying the 50 is good
so you can also just buy a 50 strike
call if you want but i personally would
sell the 130 that is too expensive to me
and i i don't care to cap my performance
above 130 because this is my target so
everything above 130 is for me good to
sell in terms of performance i mean
so here
my trade would be this one and i prefer
to load twice this okay for 900 us
dollars you can make up to 14 000 then
just doing one like this that is roughly
the same price but that at 130 it has
only 7 000 so doing a cold spread
actually helps you to double your
profits at 130 but you just need to
sacrifice your performance above 130
which is for me totally fine to do now
game stop
bam
so
here we have so same kind of thing we
are going to sell 150 so it's the
support we're gonna buy roughly 220 okay
225 next resistance and here we can go
only to the 690 i think
no sorry this one is not listed
uh
okay see i i need to go to october to
see this strike
so i go to october maturity by the way
this spreadsheet is available on my
discord guys i share it with you and i
explain to you how it works for those
who are
interested okay i'm trying to see
here we go so you sell this one 150 you
buy the 220 and you cap your performance
here so gamestop is much more expensive
so it involves bigger amount of money
so here zero 15
okay let me just rebuild my chart
all right so here we go and you can see
that by doing this strategy you can make
up to 45 000 us dollars but selling 150
put will uh be very expensive in terms
of margin requirements because uh you
can see that the maximum loss is 15 000
us dollars so it's not easy to make this
kind of strategy so let's maybe forget
here about this and just go for cold
spread but as you can see it's very
expensive so maybe we can go to a higher
strike right
if you go to a higher strike okay you
still need to spend 1 500 us dollars but
you can make up to 40 000 but this is
for october so i think that it's
achievable but to be honest this premium
is very expensive to me you can see that
we're buying here a volatility of 145
which is a lot compared to the realized
volatility of 110 so this is a bit of a
scam but we are selling this one so we
are kind of
balancing our risk here
so feel free guys to just come on my
discord download the spreadsheet and do
it yourself try to see what kind of cool
strategies you want to make pay
attention to the volatility and to the
time value that are the two most
important parameters when you try to
build an option strategy so that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video i hope i managed to explain the
reasons why i'm bullish on both gamestop
and amc looking at the synthetic short
looking at the regular short looking at
the price action patterns like breakout
divergences i hope also managed to
explain what kind of strategies you can
make that are safe that are not going to
make you lose money if amc suddenly
crashes for some reason and that allow
you to benefit from potential squeeze so
if you did enjoy this video please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys